[Music]
how rich is real rich right
jeff jeff bezos is rich is real [ __ ]
right i like your rapping
how rich real rich right
rich rich right all right thank you damn
all right so a historic bridge is to be
dismantled so jeff bezos's
half a billion dollar yacht can get
through the super yacht holy [ __ ] that's
crazy that's power that's power
the government where's the bridge it's
about drive it's about power so
oh my bad i just wanted my own head for
something no that was good so this is
actually in uh the netherlands
wow what did the netherlanders think
uh they're they're cool with that
they're like yeah go ahead like we'll
swim jeff it's fine we love amazon
amazon's great thank you i thought all
of them didn't like um
rich rich people like i thought europe
was like nah yeah because isn't that
where amsterdam is yeah well they're
definitely building the largest private
yacht ever out there it's 417 feet oh
they're building it oh they're boat
people they're boat people i don't know
about all of them
yeah they're the dutch
i like that stereotype they're all
broken they're both people and hookers
dude have you seen their their their
clocks from the viking days yeah don't
you know
don chano you guys never heard of the
[ __ ] dutchies a dutch easter is that
the one they're building or is that jeff
bezos boat is it the biggest one
that's a yacht dude that looks like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was like a [ __ ] yeah
it's a cruise ship paul allen used to
have the biggest yacht
and then all these billionaires were
like pissed because paul allen had the
big yacht and they're all trying to get
the biggest yacht then paul island dies
and then yeah i think bez is going to
have the biggest yacht when when it's
completed
it'll be considered the biggest sailing
yacht in the world which is no doubt an
exciting prospect for a former amazon
boss but it's uh pretty much the he
names it y721
i don't know why uh it's being built at
the oceano shipyard in
al blassardam in the netherlands and in
order to get out to sea it needs to pass
under the historic historic conan
bridge in rotterdam also known as de
hiff
according to dutch publication regine
monde the local council had pledged
never to dismantle the iconic bridge
again after it was renovated in 2017. he
did this 2017
we'll never do this again except for
jeff bezos so he's he's gonna pay for
them to he'll build him a new one yes he
is going to foot the bill
because he really wants that boat uh and
he obviously has the money to do so but
what if it's like shitty it's just like
cardboard with amazon package tape
that's like because he's free
he does an amazon basics bridge
it says it on there it says historic
basic spread you guys ever ordered like
a um
like contracting work on amazon you
could contract the work they'll build
your [ __ ] bed they'll build your oh
when you order the product and then you
pay the extra fee i see what you mean
they'll come to your house and build
that ship that's tight yeah that makes
sense though that makes sense let's
start but you meant like asking for like
a contract you're like like a house
or some [ __ ] i'm pretty sure it'll start
to get amazon just like
mexican workers yeah you get to choose
quantity five exclude russians you have
like a whole race list
the russians do work pretty hard though
[ __ ] yeah my ac guy my hvac guy used to
be a russian dude that guy non-stop he
would tell me about how my air
conditioner sucks and how i need to get
a new one and he and he would climb up
on the [ __ ] roof himself because
sabotage it to make sure you get a new
one well the ladder was always the
ladder was always blocked off because it
yet the hoa has to open it so he would
always just climb over the all the
steel he was a badass dude he didn't
give a [ __ ] he's like carrying equipment
on his back damn i was like dude if you
fall i'm just walking away
but i'm just walking away it's your
property i'm not rushing you just step
over him every day while he's dead
hey hey i didn't i don't know who he is
did i show the uh the bridge yet here
let me show you a photo of the bridge
yeah when you got money you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you i wonder what this
bridge looks like what if it just sucks
what if it's such so it's this still
historic wow wow it can't fit in there
oh that's so great i think it's the [ __ ]
the height i think it ends up being the
height or something like that you can't
fit through there he couldn't yeah he's
gonna get his uh yacht built in another
dude you know he's like he's like make
it bigger and then they're like what
he's like make it [ __ ] they're like it
won't fit through that i don't want it
i'll i'll fix the bridge i'll give a
[ __ ] yeah it's probably because it's
impo it's employing so many people to
work on that yacht that everyone's like
yeah we want the jobs what would you
guys do if you're jeff bezos right now
you're jeff bezos tonight what do you do
i'd feed the world oh for [ __ ]
you weren't expecting that right
that kind of threw me off i'm not gonna
lie i was like everyone gets a [ __ ]
cheeseburger
man
soda yeah all right we're going to start
with the soda soda what brand their
choice oh okay see because i make it
about them what if they're my wife like
i don't drink soda amazon's choice soda
i think everyone should enjoy what
americans get to enjoy free refills
that's a very american thing right so
i'm gonna open up that to the world okay
and it's it's from the fountain and it's
from that machine that you can [ __ ]
choose i want orange coke i want yeah
that's great the one at boston market
yeah but i'm gonna add it with
every drink of the world
you got [ __ ] [ __ ] fanta and [ __ ]
and all kinds of cool [ __ ] that's gonna
already happen in the world it already
has that
really yeah i never drink phantoms
that's why we love them i thought
phantom was a [ __ ] south american i
had like a ago fresca or something like
that yeah all right
whatever you want man whatever you want
you know calculus vote for this guy
whatever you want
we're gonna do that whatever you want
man you get a soda machine we're gonna
get the [ __ ] chinese yogurt drink oh
those are delicious yeah is there gonna
be yakult there's gonna be probiotic
yaakov yeah what about some barbell
brigades steve's like what the [ __ ] is
this horchata barbell brigade
what about julia what about julia marcha
whatever you want use your dragon fruit
how are you gonna pay for this whatever
you want
i've been waiting for this guy to get
rich for so [ __ ] long
and to find out that all he's gonna do
is give me free soda is like the biggest
bummer of my life i think
it's it's a 10 course meal though it
just starts with us
what's the appetizer what's the
appetizer with the soda because you have
to pair it with something wow the first
is going to be a cobb salad i'm not
hungry
salad
a [ __ ] cough salad with soda that's a
lot of ingredients for mass production
even the natives in the amazon you can
start with the everybody gets a cop
style you just get a [ __ ] is that is
that why is that american i'm gonna make
it a cabbage cobb salad just a little
bit different it's just a quarter
cabbage cobb salad in that with soy
sauce it's [ __ ] bomb on my belief in
this politician
all right what's round three yeah
all right pepperoni pizza for everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
i was trying to heal the world the
mongolians everybody new guinea everyone
pepperoni what about low-key that is the
that's you can't have that yeah
uh uh i'll make a chicken pepperoni for
them yeah flatbread it's it's yeah with
not me with naan oh can you imagine that
a non-pepperoni pizza that would be
delicious
he's so mad guys jeff basil's he's
making non-pepperoni
[Laughter]
chicken chicken pepperoni garlic naan
pepperoni oh what about lavash wraps for
everybody it's all he's only doing
fusion food why why so much fusion no
what pisses me off is he could just do
this right now you just go [ __ ] make
a call like not pepperoni pizza right
now yeah well but he's using his jet
based off no man feed it though for the
feed
what would you rather have joe do send
like 20 missiles to the moon
and try to blow it up yeah dude take a
picture of his [ __ ] dick and then
have it made into a [ __ ] statue and
he buys like long island harbor and he
puts his [ __ ] statue of his dick or
something that's a very steep green
japanese that's just where i start okay
i'm feeding the world
without the dick projection part steve
what would you do with jeff bezos's
money i would just make donuts
and feed the world
uh you know glazed donuts the most
boring donut no no no strawberry but
what if someone's allergic to strawberry
that's right glaze is good yeah
you think
what about lactose
glaze is good
that's your campaign slogan glaze is
good
jitsukawa 2024.
running for jeff bezos
vote for me
when i was a kid my mom would talk about
when we win the lottery because that was
basically how they invested anything
they were like well you know we're going
to win the lottery when we hit the
bottom that's what we're investing they
play every day oh yeah played every week
yeah my ground played every day and when
we win the lottery we're gonna have a
taco bell in our house so for me i'm
like dude having a taco bell in my
[ __ ] house that'd be tight jeff bezos
[ __ ] would you do a cantina i would do
it absolutely a cantina have you been to
taco bell cantina i've never been i
haven't been no i heard it's great
sounds good though it sounds like a
great idea is it like a set down
restaurant with margaritas you can get
married there even oh yeah yeah it would
be a really cool thing to do
basil's every week you would resurrect a
dead restaurant if you said person yes
what's the first one when you would
resurrect soup plantation
you already know dude i was so sad with
you i think i'm more destructive i would
want to create natural disasters that
aren't native to that area what is it
sim city he wants to be sim city yeah
yeah dude that's a that's a marvel vlog
i'll bring like earthquakes to new york
or some [ __ ] or like [ __ ] kano's in
las vegas
you do know that this is another version
of genocide right so we can share an
experience
so if they could relate to people on
night the east and the west coast
together okay that's pretty cool i don't
i don't know if that's the way but you
know i command you why you never thought
what a tornado feels like that's true
cool if i ever see a tornado in hawaii
i'll be like [ __ ] bark got rich
[Laughter]
yeah i didn't know that jeff bezels can
buy volcanoes in vegas no you make them
there's one at the mirage
duh anthony guys come on guys you just
make them
that's like a kid
make them like we did in science fair
those were cool or the onion ring ones
at benihana's oh yeah yeah
you know how to make them too you put a
bigger giant onion ring it's a picture
it's not even a real volcano just like
but it's so destructive
what do you do if you're jeff bezos
gilbert dude i don't know if i honestly
want to appoint these two guys i just
want to see what happens that's true
because i'd be too like death in life
very quickly
yeah i like natural disasters like crazy
okay
so would you guys combine ideas there
you guys are good friends
well at the same time right you get a
guy floating in an air with a
non-fucking pepperoni pizza he's been
spitting in a tornado yeah yeah so he
doesn't get to eat though okay number
one top natural disaster go tsunami
tsunami wow that's so japanese
oh god he regretted after he said he was
like
number one
tokyo tsunamis there's tsunami videos
and then people go up and because
there's like the water gets drawn out so
then p the tourists go up and they're
like oh look you can see all the coral
and they're like get out of there you
stupid son of a [ __ ] and then they're
like hey look it's a starfish and then
they're going oh
there's a tsunami and then they're
trying to run and joe's like
he runs towards it
oh tsunamis
i think i like sinkholes
you guys sound like two kindergarteners
i think i got a thing called though
that's pretty cool right really like
unexpected mascot that's why they're
best friends
[Music]
you